desde hace tres semanas la sala de
enfermedades infecciosas del hospital
universitario de montpellier ha estado a
plena capacidad sus 10 camas están
ocupadas por pacientes de kobe 19 se
está volviendo cada vez más difícil con
mensajes de los médicos de urgencias que
buscan espacios y nosotros por otro lado
que realmente no podemos ayudar
entendemos su angustia estamos haciendo
lo mejor que podemos seguro esto ha
dejado a los equipos exhaustos y sin
saber por qué realmente está sucediendo
francia ha visto un aumento en las
hospitalizaciones por kobe 19 que
pasaron de menos de 200 al día a
mediados de octubre a un nivel de 900 al
día aunque la creciente o las 6 regiones
han activado el llamado plan blanco en
hospitales y clínicas mecanismo para que
las autoridades sanitarias puedan
manejar la crisis y ayudar a reorganizar
los departamentos de urgencias en
particular con la cancelación de
cualquier procedimiento no urgente con
el objetivo de liberar camas y reforzar
al personal las autoridades sanitarias
han estado transmitiendo el mensaje de
que un hospital no siempre debería ser
la primera opción de las personas y
robinson lo máximo ahora estamos al
límite de lo que puede hacer nuestro
personal en las salas de emergencia pero
claramente debe marcar el número de
emergencia 15 en caso de duda y
continuar consultando a su médico de
cabecera
objetos donde exista esto ocurre cuando
se vive una espiral ascendente de
infecciones en francia debido a la
variante o micro sólo el miércoles más
de 60 mil casos de kobe fueron
registrados en 24 horas